Trump's renewed his attacks on the World
Health Organization's threatened to cut
us funding for good he's written to the
head of the UN's health agency with a
30-day ultimatum now to make big changes
or permanently lose the United States
membership Trump accuses the WH o of
mishandling the corona virus outbreak in
caring to China there are a puppet of
China there China centric to put it
nicer but they're a puppet of China we
help fund the World Health Organization
we use it like everyone else does they
gave us a lot of very bad advice
terrible advice they were wrong so much
always on the side of China China paid
40 million dollars last year and we've
been paying 450 million dollars a year
for many years somehow that doesn't work
out too well well Trump says the w-h-o
had made several inaccurate and
misleading claims about the coronavirus
and accuses the agency of simply moving
too slowly he described his letter as
self explanatory although it doesn't
specify what the agency has to do to
maintain White House funding the letter
just calls for the w-h-o to demonstrate
independence from China more than 100
countries are calling for a probe into
the wh o--'s coronavirus response an
update on that next then from our T's
Peter Oliver well this is all taking
place against the backdrop of the 73rd
United Nations Health Assembly taking
place perhaps the most important one of
those gatherings albeit even if this one
is taking place virtually that there's
ever been on a global stage and while it
would seem like the perfect opportunity
for nations to come together and work
collectively to try and establish a
vaccine to get aid to those nations that
need it most what it's being used for
what this platform has been used for by
the United States is an opportunity to
point the finger of blame firmly at the
World Health Organization and accuse
them of essentially letting this crisis
spin out of control there was a failure
by this organization to obtain the
information that the world needed and
that failure cost many lives in an
apparent attempt to conceal this
outbreak at least one member state made
a mockery of their transparency
obligations with tremendous cost for the
entire world u.s. president has
suspended
funding for the World Health
Organization amid this pandemic his
critics say that he's using them
essentially as a scapegoat for his own
administration's failings in dealing
with the covert 19 pandemic saying
that's if you look at the United States
having the highest number of cases
around the world the highest number of
fatalities as well and also looking at
the spiraling unemployment figures in
the United States China for their part
and the World Health Organization of the
night vehemently these claims that have
been made against them by the United
States from Beijing's point-of-view
they've pledged money to countries that
have been hardest hit by the corona
virus they also sent doctors and aid to
Africa and other developing nations
China will provide 2 billion u.s.
dollars over two years to help with the
covert 19 response and with economic and
social development in affected countries
especially developing countries of the
world Health Organization has said that
there will be independent inquiry into
how they responded to the kovat crisis
they're director-general says that yes
there were some things that slipped
through the net but that they've learned
from them and he stood vehemently behind
his organization while it's also being
calls for unity and a unified approach
to fighting the virus from two of
Europe's heaviest hitters so Nick on
your nissan of thoughts only if we join
forces will we beat this pandemic and we
need the w-h-o because of its
irreplaceable coordinating role here we
have the opportunity to provide a
unified response to the pandemic that is
free of complacency and unfounded
accusations no country can solve this
problem alone we must work together the
dub Late Show is irreplaceable
it needs enhanced resources particularly
to provide support to developing
countries which must be our greatest
concern we are as strong as the weakest
of systems for the World Health Assembly
continues on Tuesday and be looking for
more of that unified approach to
fighting the virus and less of
the finger-pointing that we saw on
Monday
you